and the Iron Horse the Earth Shaker the
fire breather which tramples down the
hills which outruns the laggard winds
which leaps over the rivers which grinds
the rocks to powder and breaks down the
gates of the mountain he too shall build
an Empire and an epic putnam's magazine
in the 19th century trains moved America
the locomotives symbolized modernity and
man's domination of nature it connected
the east and west coast and helped
settle the frontier and by 1916 rail
accounted for 98 of inner city travel
everything changed
air travel and the personal automobile
offering Travelers the convenience of
point-to-point Mobility led to the
decline of Passenger rail use but trains
were still useful for hauling free
the remaining passenger rail companies
were going bankrupt so in 1970 Richard
Nixon signed a bill that led to the
creation of Amtrak a new publicly owned
privately run company that was supposed
to operate at a profit
14 years after Amtrak was created the
Reagan Administration wanted to
eliminate Federal subsidies Amtrak was
created as I understand it as a two-year
test to see if we could have a
for-profit corporation
and I'd say that the record of Amtrak 11
billion dollars later we're looking now
at 8 billion for the next decade
Congressional Democrats prevailed and
the federal government continued
providing subsidies the cost is getting
substantially better and there's a
consensus across the country even in the
administration that the the federal
assistance to um Amtrak has been going
down there's more that's coming out of
the fare box
1980s but then climbed right back up in
the 1990s yet by the time Amtrak Joe was
elected president the system was in
financial trouble so Biden passed a
trillion dollar infrastructure bill with
66 billion dollars earmarked for rail
yet train enthusiasts want Washington to
send billions more often sharing fantasy
maps of a U.S high-speed Network that
would rival Europe's but did we give up
too quickly on private passenger rail
can it still be commercially viable
without massive subsidies in the
Sunshine State one company is betting
that it can under very specific
conditions people have been talking
about introducing passenger trains in
Florida for a long time probably 20
years or more Mike renninger is the CEO
of brightline trains the company is
starting service between Miami and
Orlando a trip that will take under
three hours each way compared to riding
Amtrak which takes 5 hours and 40
minutes in One Direction and 7 hours and
48 minutes in the other this is the
first privately funded Inner City
passenger rail system in this case Tree
in more than a century Ben Deport is a
senior vice president at brightline it's
totally different than anything that
you're familiar with whether it's with
train travel or public bus travel unlike
Amtrak service brightline's Florida
train won't receive government subsidies
and reininger is betting that he can
turn a profit passenger rail he says
makes commercial sense under specific
conditions such as in this case by
connecting two popular cities that are
about 250 miles apart because 250 to 350
miles is too far to drive and too short
to fly and when you introduce a train
into distances that length you can
approximate the time of flying
significantly improve the time of
driving and you can offer it at a price
point that makes it an economic
proposition the passengers we spoke to
in the Miami station who traveled from
Boca Raton said that the hour and 15
minute ride beats getting stuck in
traffic it's just more convenient versus
driving I mean traffic in Florida has
become so bad trades faster it's
comfortable you're passive you can read
emails read a book let's do a podcast
it's much much easier the Miami station
is modern and sleek and the train is
clean quiet and smooth with flexible
seating arrangements brightline is also
the southeast fastest train reaching
speeds of 125 miles an hour between
Miami and Orlando though significantly
slower than High-Speed Rail in many
parts of the world it beats the Region's
Amtrak which tops out at 80 miles an
hour in Florida so when brightline came
to be we modernized the existing track
we double tracked it in certain areas we
improved 156 grade Crossings improved or
enhanced 56 Bridges brightline save
money by upgrading existing
infrastructure and paying for permission
to build new tracks adjacent to existing
highways and traffic corridors the
company also invested in real estate
along the Route anticipating that the
existence of its service will boost
property values they took a clue from
the Hong Kong mass transit Railway which
from its start developed as a
combination of real estate and
transportation you know the train feeds
the real estate the real estate helps
the train Robert Poole is the director
of Transportation policy at reason
Foundation which publishes reason TV and
reason magazine they're buying some
adjacent land that was low use and
adding real estate there too so it's a
very it's a different business model
Amtrak has never done anything like that
so why can't the U.S have a network of
high-speed trains similar to the ones
crisscrossing Europe for one thing
European rail depends heavily on
taxpayer subsidies in the whole world we
only know of two High-Speed Rail lines
that claim to have covered their full
cost the cost of building it and the
ongoing cost from the fare box revenues
that's the first tgv line in France from
Paris to Lyon and the first one in Japan
the tokaido line from Tokyo to Osaka the
bottom line thing is massive subsidies
both subsidies to build it and subsidies
to operate the U.S hasn't developed
High-Speed Rail in part because of its
geography the most populous U.S cities
are far more spread out than those in
Europe and China so it's easier to fly
for shorter distances cars and buses are
more flexible and much cheaper to
operate what America has is tremendous
road infrastructure tremendous Freight
rail infrastructure in the 50s
large-scale Financial commitments were
made to developing both of those assist
and on the back of a brand new
interstate highway system and fantastic
American-made cars and cheap gas America
became a place where we moved Freight by
train and people by cars there has been
one ambitious effort to build High-Speed
Rail in the U.S in California but that
project turned into something so foolish
that it's almost a crime according to
Quentin L Copp the former state senator
who was crucial in rallying support for
a 10 billion dollar Bond measure to
build High-Speed Rail in the state he
became a fierce opponent of the project
when it ran out of money and the agency
in charge he says broke its promises to
voters the 520 mile Railway which has
received more than 20 billion dollars in
state and federal subsidies but after 15
years of construction they've only laid
track for 170 Mile Stretch in the
Central Valley Brian Kelly who took over
as the CEO of the California High-Speed
Rail Authority in 2018 says that the
project was initially mismanaged they
got into construction at a sequence and
they got into construction before the
authority was ready as a result of that
if you're trying to get into
construction you've got a contractor
mobilized to build but you're behind on
right-of-way you haven't moved all the
utilities then you're going to run into
delays and costs the cost of the project
has ballooned from 33 billion dollars to
about
128 billion can you give us some reasons
for why that number nearly quadrupled
since the beginning of the project and I
mean what is a 33 billion dollar cost
estimate in 2008 which was 15 years ago
was before any work was done none of the
environmental work was done none of the
design work was done it was an estimate
based on paper according to the New York
Times as of last year although the rail
Authority was spending 1.8 million
dollars daily the project wasn't even on
track to be done by the end of the
century Kelly suggests that wasn't
enough to get construction going we need
to spend about between 80 and 100
million a month you know more than 3
million a day but that's the pace we
need to be on to get done on schedule as
Governor Brown used to say you enjoy
Martini on the train and you get there
in about three hours it's a much better
way to move so do Californians want to
do that
my answer is yes I hope their answer is
yes the project climbed in price in part
because its planners decided not to use
existing traffic corridors or rails
opting for a longer route with many more
stops politicization that led to this
really flawed plan that's costing way
way more than if they followed I-5 and
didn't have to do as much massive
tunneling and the real estate
acquisition in the endless litigations
having defied hundreds and hundreds of
farms in half and fight with them over
condemning their land that has delayed
things dramatically brightline is also
building in California developing its
own 218 Mile Rail Line running from Las
Vegas to Rancho Cucamonga which is on
the outskirts of Los Angeles the company
is betting that Travelers will opt to
leave their cars at home and avoid
airport hassle we acquired property in
Victor Valley we acquired property in
Las Vegas we have rights of way from the
California and Nevada Departments of
Transportation so we were able to do it
without eminent domain reiniger says
California's High-Speed Rail Project has
to clear far more regulatory hurdles
than brightline they have different
environmental regulations that they're
subject to and their system profile is
just very different than the
entrepreneurial private sector approach
but unlike its Florida Line brightline
West is not going to be a test of
whether rail can be commercially viable
because the company is banking on about
three billion dollars in federal
subsidies through Joe Biden's
infrastructure investment and jobs act
pool is skeptical it becomes far less of
a business venture and much more of a we
can do Grand things because we don't
have to worry about what it costs and
that's that's a gross oversimplification
but there's a different kind of
mentality made in America by Americans
union labor true high-speed 200 miles an
hour fully electric renewable use of
power now if you check the box on every
benefit that you can possibly bring to
bear following on its success in Florida
reiniger says brightline is looking for
commercially viable rail corridors all
over the country we're looking all
around the country at 250 to 300 mile
separated cities Portland Seattle is one
that looks attractive to us Texas has
you know has a number of them Dallas
Houston Dallas San Antonio San Antonio
Houston
shall not he strengthen leagues Crush
trees and Conquer enemies shall he not
run from Ocean to Ocean and iron Mercury
the Swift Herald of the state beautiful
but bearing Terror swallowing the ground
with fierceness and rage ah well it is a
long way to the Epic of the Iron Horse
in the 21st century autonomous vehicles
are more likely to swallow the ground
with fierceness and rage and to be
capable of building an empire in an epic
but brightline does represent a true
test of whether there are narrow cases
in which Travelers actually still value
passenger rail enough to pay for it with
their own money
[Music]
thank you